so are you meet somebody they give me a
girl than your incident like Saudi - I'm
like why ten bar over at blog live like
oh so what do you really do and I'm like
no I really do that in fact I was there
as a couple hours ago
I really do that over the last 25 years
I've spent the vast majority of that
working the front house restaurants
bartending and serving managing yes
server and bartender has been in my
blood for two decades I've done fine
dining and I'm working wine bars and
I've done a breakfast joints got
breakfast joints are so much fun he gets
in you and it's an addiction the few
years back I was dating a girl at the
time that was encouraging me she was
working in corporate is very successful
so I pursued having a normal job that's
when I had my desk job my normal job and
I ended up working in insurance I went
through the training and I went through
all this I was getting up every morning
and having my coffee driving into work I
would sit in this cubicle
that's what other people want to do and
I can't judge anybody for it but for me
I just heard that one morning like I
just hit me and I sat down and I just
started crying
I went from tanning bar to having a desk
job and I went from working four days a
week to working five days a week and I
took a third pay cut I guess I kind of
convinced myself having a more adult job
was the next thing I had to be doing
once I let go that a certain working
weekend brunch add a little joy in my
neighborhood and like I was working
seven days a week we were like a party
not she working seven days a week and
I'm like - no I meant worked five days a
week and I get to go with fun at a
restaurant on the weekends it was like
that oh my god I was moving again I felt
energized I was served like it was
amazing how much it was getting back to
me
when you're in the Boren restaurant
business so you need to most fascinating
people from all walks of life if you
will travel the world a minister's
acupuncturist Master Masons people I
would never have ever come into contact
with if I didn't work behind the bar on
the floor of a restaurant I worked four
days a week and I have three days that I
don't
to be anywhere unless I've scheduled
something for me it's really important
to have downtime where I get to work on
side projects and I get to have time to
travel right before I came to do this I
had a meeting with a guy about a
business model for a new concept at home
I'm working on three woodworking
projects I used to write for a magazine
host beer tasting classes I know that my
lifestyle is not the most traditional
but it's the way I need it to be
necessarily you just quit giving so much
of a [ __ ] about what everybody will
think